Bilder von Männern und Frauen die auf
unseren Straßen den Terror der Hamas
feiern die ihrem Hass gegen Israel und
gegen unsere jüdischen Mitbürger und
Mitbürger freien Lauf lassen das ist
abscheulich das ist menschenverachten
das widerspricht allen Werten den wir
als Land verpflichtet sind Hass und
Hetze nehmen wir nicht tatenlos
hin
wer die Verbrechen der Hass verherrlicht
oder ihre Symbole verwendet macht sich
in Deutschland strafbar wer Mord und
Todschlag billigt oder zu straftatten
aufruft macht sich strafbar wer
israelische Flaggen verbrennt der macht
sich
strafbar wer eine Terrororganisation wie
die Hamas unterstützt der macht sich
strafbar das bundesinnen wird ein
Betätigungsverbot für die Hamas in
Deutschland
erlassen ein Verein wie samidun dessen
Mitglieder brutalste Terrorakte auf
offener Straße feiern wird in
Deutschland
[Applaus]
[Musik]
verboten